Hey welcome back to miss ow why am i
whispering because they're so one bet I
know just getting I've got recommender
where's the rooftop it's over here right
well that's nice
hey call me later I haven't hot date but
a chest did it did it did it I did it I
did it and you did it I did it turn a
part of me so looks like a [ __ ] space
alien or some [ __ ] I obtained me south
eyes like well isn't that wonderful
aha
so we have three out of six items that's
this fan-fucking-tastic which ones do we
have we have boys bathroom it should be
[ __ ] good what the hell the [ __ ]
car went through all that it appears
that Kudo is dead well no [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I figured it out parts of the Misao
so one of these missiles legs all right
what do we got now arms legs eyes head
we didn't need her heart and her dick
what about him about one of the lockers
maybe Nell ah nothing in it ah yeah why
would someone put her brain in there
that's [ __ ] nasty
ah okay well that means my blog but I'm
on the road today bro-chachos we just
need one more item uh-huh we're going to
the girls
the four-eyed or didn't she say that as
a hint
well done did lado John did lead a delay
better yeah yes I got a feeling yeah
what
well someone likes to play with toilets
glad I'm not the only one
however that let look at what I don't
trust that all right on trusses
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta do that
again
okay just dog cap don't kill me don't
kill me
nope what did I say a second ago don't
kill don't kill me don't kill me but I
what there are coins in the toilets pick
them up yes please
now I can buy myself a soda Oh shoulder
sue where Hey
let's win a PEZ a jolly would come [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you just [ __ ] you [ __ ] your
mama [ __ ] your couch [ __ ] [ __ ] your
couch okay where is that vending machine
there we go
I'm nailing this this item there we go
BAM I'm gonna buy myself some juice and
I'm gonna enjoy it
and Pocari sweat god damnit that's
disgusting well we got to drink it
anyway Yolo right we drinking sweat all
right uh-huh oh I know maybe this [ __ ]
wants it you know that [ __ ] in the
hallway that is a let me progress and
[ __ ] I bet she wants it [ __ ] you hey
Shane what is that hallway
parrot it all right eyebrow you want
some sweat don't sweat it bro get it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] all right doo doo doo
doo so some people are saying that Lee
taxer is like IR whatever nothing really
uh-huh all right you want some sweat bro
you giving me this Pocari sweat thank
you you know you're a good girl a pretty
cute you could be my girl fall in love
like duh yeah [ __ ] what what why this is
reg chunky butt juice did you do this
per Delia I you hate me that much
it wasn't me excuse you but what is this
it looks like a king oh damn it I'll
discuss it I gotta sleep don't watch me
yeah
- Delia is such an [ __ ] like drink
this juice it's sweat don't sweat it
all right [ __ ] what did she want what
can I do for you nothing really
all right why did I get that looks like
a pretty cute heart okay well we're
gonna go back to the Mandrake thingy or
whatever I think it's over here
hi oh come here come here little man
Jake oh come to mama
yes that's right it didn't work but why
did it startled me I come to mama come
to mama
poor little thing it fainted harvest
assault you bet your sweet ass I got a
harvest that salt oh that's right that's
some good salt from that man dick I
could have just gone through a [ __ ]
kitchen but no we're gonna make we're
gonna make the Mandrake [ __ ] fake and
[ __ ] oh yeah I would totally figure that
out by myself fizzy let's sprinkle the
salt seems the evil spirit went away oh
because oh I get it
I
again wow what a party I missed a head
chef I and I okay what but that was
playing so nicely why does no one ever
listen if you [ __ ] murder them
ah
thank you for listening
[ __ ] well done ah it gave me a
treasure man that what did I get a desk
well this better have porn on it it's a
there's a piano played
to have gum rest I'm back in not like
but hey a booth did oh yeah we got this
last night what did I end the last
episode I am glad but how do I get there
don't kill me ah [ __ ] I kill how do I
get past without dying oh it's here
please and put the password uh I don't
know
let's probably have something to do with
this ah cool this peeps oh I get it
their colors so zero seven eight five
four zero seven eight four five zero
seven eight nine five zero seven eight
nine nine [ __ ] suck seven seven Oh what
what the hell just happened
well at least we got rid of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] please insert another password Oh
again it's like a holder to figure it
out
why do I have to do it again oh well
yeah what oh I got her heart now that's
nice alright that means we can go and
sacrifice NBA
ah but before that we will say bye to
man Drake sketch more in my hate
I just tried to rhyme with man Drake and
that's all I could come up with it was a
very inspirational it wasn't very good
man hey that's life in general isn't it
alright let's go to the temple to Burt
what there's one guy who hasn't died ah
oh it's that blonde [ __ ] alright well
yes
clop up just flat that [ __ ] over there
that's alright thanks very nice
now we shall sacrifice that and girly
Gullu
alright what's gonna happen all the
parts were offered but nothing happens
why isn't anything happening we have to
kill that last [ __ ] they all need to
die someone who's supposed to die is not
dead yet for shizzle sacrifice a body on
the cows with how do I suck up cousin
buddy
I'll have all the items I split I'll
always still have the money even though
I whatever okay let's go and kill those
[ __ ] maybe I need to die mm maybe I
was horrible I heard the ending it's
really like dark and [ __ ] but maybe she
maybe there's something what can I do
for you nothing really what about this
guy he's not dead he's supposed to die
snore let's banish the [ __ ] out of him
have a can well [ __ ]
yeah tens I guess mmm you offered all
the parts that's all why didn't you undo
the what didn't maybe mr. Nick around I
was something all right well go to that
guy he's such a swagalicious guy
I'm sure he'll help us okay I have a
friend I say you sacrifice her body at
the altar however this alone doesn't
seem to have undo the curse we'll need a
live sacrifice a live sacrifice did you
see the red tombstones in the abbot's
the spirit of one of those names are
there must be sucker okay there are
fortunes own that's what I said you
don't have to tell me this three of them
already names okay
someone just must be the last sacrifice
then I'll I'll be the sacrifice that's
impossible those two sums are tools of
her hatred surely one who has not earned
her resentment could not carve their
name there I set out you set out to save
her she could not hate you there are
others still alive think well on who
must be the sacrifice someone whose
missile hates hmm I can't sacrifice
myself well there's only one guy left so
it's not like it's really difficult and
I was there Eddie what Mia what do you
want what do you want what do you want
hey yo yo hey ty oh I don't know what I
just said okay well
it's time to kill you hello hello
I always sleeping perfect hey I can't
think of anyone left but Toma that
Machado had a grudge against yes miss ow
forgive me apologize in the after whoa
calm down that's that's a bit bro tell
oh okay
well he's that party hard okay
did you say that look at that was not me
oh so you choose Tom up inside my that's
alright leave the cops to me that should
be all the requires - under the cards
now Fidelia god save me save for us we
have to kill four people and Babli
bobbidi the body to save one evil ghost
that's a lot of work that's a lot of
work girl
are there a glowing shed oh they're all
glowing - what do I do don't win it out
their shares miss Howe thank you for
finding me wait don't go miss huh
what that was quick enough what happened
to with her massage she thanked me I'm
sure it's fine now I see huh
I thought your breath said there was a
weird ending that's not a weird at all
it's getting right out teacher let's go
outside all right I'm sorry I had to cut
it here but it's my girlfriend's dad's
birthday and we're going out so I don't
have time to make it longer next episode
will include an entire ending plus the
bonus ending or the true ending or
whatever so yeah like afarid if you
enjoyed subscribe combo today and i'll
see you in the exciting ending it's
gonna be really really worth watching
trust me
I mean that depends what you like but
it's what
you